MICHAEL BROOKS:
So again, welcome.
I'm glad to see you guys here.
I appreciate you taking
time out to be here today.
I'm really excited
to be here today.
And this is my excited
face, by the way.
[LAUGHTER]
It's close to my calm face.
But it's amazing to
see a corporation that
promotes wellness so
much in an organization.
I've worked in technology.
I work right now in
technology and in corporations
for the last 20 years.
So to see the establishment
like this, or what they promote
or what they provide for
you guys is quite inspiring.
And I do hope that this catches
on to more organizations
and that they promote wellness.
It's such an integral part.
I think-- I was
reflecting on it earlier--
that it's acknowledging
the entire person.
Right?
You're not just a
being here doing work.
There's a spiritual side to
you, a wellness side to you,
a human side to you.
So it's nice to see
that in an organization.
So I'm going to talk today
for about 30 or 45 minutes.
I'd really prefer this
be a conversation.
I've been told sometimes
people don't ask questions,
but I hope people
will ask questions.
Some of this information
around mindful and meditation,
it's kind of esoteric.
It's kind of a loaded term,
both of them-- meditation,
mindfulness, yoga, happiness.
All of these things
are loaded these days.
So clarification to me is key.
Definitions are key.
So if something is
not clear, or if you
want to talk a little
bit more about something,
please raise your hand.
We do have a microphone.
And one of my
friends in the back
will pass that around to you.
Please do ask questions
as we go through.
All right.
So I wrote this little
pamphlet last year,
had it published,
about mindfulness.
And I'm going to speak
to the concepts in this.
I'm not going to be reading
from the book or anything.
But I'll be speaking
to this quite a bit.
The focus on the book is
really around meditation
and mindfulness, my
experience with it.
I've been practicing meditation
for about 20 years, mindfulness
for probably about 12 years.
And I also teach weekly classes.
So what I say from this
work is that I did the work.
I've done the work with
meditation and mindfulness.
And I've helped a lot
of people along the way.
And I've learned a
tremendous amount.
And I'm still
continuing to learn.
There's no into your learning
with meditation or mindfulness.
So it's just based on my
experience and my practice
and with helping out others.
So it's evolving process.
Meditation practice,
mindless-- it's a journey.
There's no end to it.
We have these ideas, I think,
that we'll reach happiness,
or we'll reach a point and it'll
all be good or will be done.
But what I've found,
in my experience,
is that it just continues.
It just deepens.
And that's very exciting
to me-- that there's
no endpoint to any of it.
You can just continue to
grow and evolve and learn.
And with peace or
whatever you find
for meditation, that could
just deepen over time.
So I just have a few
notes to get started.
I don't really prepare
for these talks.
I just like to let it flow
however people want to talk
or whatever we
want to talk about.
But there's just a few things
I wanted to start with.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
mindfulness
for 12 years and meditation for
15, or the other way around?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah,
about 20 for meditation,
12 for mindfulness.
AUDIENCE: I'm just wondering,
because the two things are
really connected, right?
You could probably
say that mindfulness
is a consequence of
meditation or a form of it?
Just curious to see how
you distinguish the two?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yes.
And I will get to
that in just a moment.
It's a great question.
So definitions are
incredibly important to me.
And so I will get
to that exactly--
to define the difference
between the two,
or how they're actually very
similar, but good observation.
So I want to talk really quickly
about just my background.
As I said, I've been practicing
meditation for about 20 years.
I was initially interested,
mainly for spiritual reasons.
I don't teach for
spiritual anything.
I teach for whatever
people want to learn
or how meditation and
mindfulness help them with.
So a lot of people
come to my classes
with anxiety, with
stress, what have you.
That's all fine.
Meditation, mindfulness,
can help with all of that.
If you use it for a spiritual
practice, that's fantastic.
For me, it's a cornerstone
of my practice.
So I leave it open for anyone.
But my interest in it initially
came from a spiritual seeking.
When I started with
meditation-- again,
20 odd years ago--
what I initially found
was that it was really hard.
Meditation's tough.
And I like to say that up
front, because a lot of people
sit down with this idea.
They'll sit down and they're
supposed to meditate.
You see a picture of someone
meditating on a beach,
and you're like,
oh, I want that.
I want to be there.
And what they don't show
you is the photographer
on the other side, and the
model is sitting there hungry,
wanting a sandwich,
wishing the person would
take a picture so they
could get up and stretch.
So there's perceptions, right?
So I wanted that.
But I was just drawn to it.
And I continued to work
with it, with meditation.
Now, here's where I do get
into definitions around this.
So I have a very
conservative view
on what meditation
and mindfulness are.
For me, as I said
earlier, meditation
is a bit of a loaded term.
It's used a lot.
To me, there's
meditation and there's
more like relaxation techniques.
To me, meditation
is sitting down
with a formal practice,
whatever works for you,
working to try and
get the mind quiet,
to where you're not
indulging in thought,
honoring thought.
And that's why
this is a practice.
This takes time.
And to sit down, find
a technique that works,
whatever works for you--
there are people that chant.
There are people that repeat
mantras over and over.
There's all types of
techniques out there.
So look at different ones and
try one that works for you.
But the intent of meditation
is to get to a point
where your mind is quiet--
as I mentioned earlier,
not indulging in thought,
not honoring thought.
So getting to a point
where, when you first
start meditating, you start
to understand that there's
this constant churn
going on in your head,
this constant commentary driving
you forward through life,
just always evaluating,
experiencing the world,
talking, always going on.
And what you're trying
to do with meditation
is kind of carve
through that just
to stop, get out of all that
for a brief period of time,
to cut through it.
And meditation
technique is giving you
something to focus
and concentrate on
so that you're not caught up
in the churn all the time.
So you're focusing.
You have a focal point to try
and quiet all that churn down
and get to a point
where you're quiet.
When you first get
started, more than likely,
you're just going to have a
moment or two of stillness.
And in those moments, hopefully
what you'll experience,
what I experienced--
what kept driving
me forward was in that
moment, everything was OK.
The world was OK.
I was not against the world.
The world was not against me.
I was not against myself.
It was just stillness.
And in that stillness
was a tremendous amount
of peace and contentment.
That only lasted
a second or two.
But it was enough.
Like, oh shit, this rocks.
I'm doing this.
And meditation is a practice.
So like with anything,
the more you practice,
the better you'll become.
Now, what I started to
internalize and understand,
and what really
screwed me, I think,
was that I rationalized, if I
can have a moment of stillness
and peace, why can't I have
a minute, five minutes, 10
minutes, or an entire day when
my mind was quiet all day long?
Why couldn't I do that?
So I intuitively knew I could.
So I worked on meditation
for a number of years.
I really didn't know much about
my mindfulness at the time.
I was more focused just
on formal meditation.
I think it was around the
time that "The Power of Now."
came out-- Jon Kabat-Zinn
had written a few books,
"Full Catastrophe Living"-- and
I started reading those that it
started to resonate, this
idea of mindfulness--
throughout the day, trying
to get your mind quiet,
to try and be in
the present moment.
Present moment
awareness was amazing.
I loved it.
It was fantastic.
It really shifted me
and changed me a lot.
But it still didn't
take care of that churn.
I was still having that churn.
This idea of being present,
being in the moment,
not living in the future
or the past was great,
and it allowed me to be more
focused and more centered,
but I still had
that churn going on.
There was still
judgments, evaluations,
conversations going on.
And so what I wanted to do
was get rid of all that,
because that's
really what you're
doing in meditation-- trying
to carve away at all of that
to get to a point of quiet.
What I went to and learned
from after the mindfulness
with "The Power of Now"
and things like that was I
looked at [INAUDIBLE] yoga,
which is just a spiritual path.
It's a lot of self inquiry
is what it's doing,
it's focused on.
It's jut a lot of looking
inward, asking yourself, who
are you, this type of thing.
What I did at that
time is one thing
that I advocate everyone do.
And I continually do it.
Start becoming aware of
what you're thinking.
Just what are you thinking
throughout the day?
Where is your mind hanging out?
So this churn that
was going on, when
I stepped back and started to
become aware of it-- what was I
thinking?
When was I thinking it?
What was going on?
What was the result
of thinking this?
So much of what we think
is tied to our emotions.
So if we're thinking about
something absent mindedly
that upsets us or is
depressing or something,
that's going to go
on for a few minutes.
And before you know it,
you're kind of depressed.
But you may not realize why.
You may just come
up with some reason.
Oh, it's just a bad day.
But if you can
reflect back on it,
oh, for the last
10 minutes, I was
thinking about this
horrible break up and all
these bad relationships,
and I'll never
have a happy relationship,
and I should just give up now.
It's like, whoa, I
don't need to do that.
There's just an awareness
of that going on.
So the fascinating
thing, and what
I write about in the
book-- it's basically
what my book is
about, 80% of this--
is starting to become aware of
what's going on, that churn.
What's happening?
And when you're able
to do that, when you're
able to figure out
what's happening,
you can start to deconstruct it.
And then you can stop doing it.
You can stop indulging in it.
The fascinating thing
I realized probably
three or four years ago,
after all this time-- so much
of thought is a habit.
Many of our thought patterns
or things that we focus on,
the way our mind hangs
out, it's a habit.
Habits can be broken.
They can be stopped.
So in using this over
the years-- and this
took years and years
of work-- I was
able to start
deconstructing these things.
What was nice was that each
one of these things that
would come up in my
mind throughout the day
would throw me off a little bit.
So I wanted to stay on a
continuum more of peace.
But if my mind is
busy making judgments,
evaluating, doing
all these things,
that pulls me away, either
into lower states of mind
or maybe higher states of mind.
But I had no control over it.
So I became obsessive.
And I was constantly monitoring
my thoughts all day long,
wanting to see,
where did my mind go?
What did it do?
What were its habits,
and how I could stop
doing some of these things.
So back to your question about
meditation and mindfulness,
to me, formal meditation
is sitting down to stop
and trying to get
mind quiet, trying
not to indulge in
all that chatter,
trying to cut through
it to get quiet.
Mindfulness-- opposite side
of the same coin-- all day
long, trying to
keep the mind quiet
and still, with an
awareness of what's
going on so you can start to
deconstruct that so that you
don't indulge in those
thought patterns anymore
and you can sustain
a more peaceful state
of mind all day long.
So you just have a
continuum is really
what I'm trying to get
to and what I focus on.
Of course, life is difficult.
There are ups and downs.
You have to ride the
waves of the world.
I live and work in the world.
I don't hide in a
monastery somewhere.
And that's a wonderful training
ground, being in the world--
especially in corporate America.
Oh my god-- politics, work,
challenges, 100 hour weeks.
I know you have no idea
what I'm talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
But I've been there.
Yeah.
I know how that works.
So this-- focusing on the
mindfulness over the years
and starting to deconstruct
these things-- freed me up
from so much of
those states of mind,
those negative things
that would draw me down,
that would connect me with the
world, that get me frustrated,
keep me in a difficult state.
So I want to talk about
some of these today.
But are there any other
questions before I get started?
That's just kind of
the basics of where
I start with meditation
and mindfulness.
And I was warned people
won't ask questions.
But I do encourage you.
If you have a question, more
than likely someone else
has a similar question
or the same question.
So if you do have a
question, just let me know.
But does that seem pretty
clear, just about mindfulness
and meditation?
It is a little bit of
a different approach.
I know there's a lot out
there with mindfulness
just about present
moment awareness.
But to me, there's so much more.
There's a lot more
to deconstruct.
But the beautiful thing is the
more you take and deconstruct
those things, the
more present you are.
And there's a deepening with it.
And it's not to say that
your life's circumstances are
going to get better.
But you can weather it
a lot more peacefully.
There is still going to be
up and downs in your life.
But if you're able to contain
a more content, peaceful state
of mind, you're not going
to be driven by it so much,
driven down, or driven
all over the place.
You can stay at a bit
of an equilibrium.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL BROOKS: Oh, real quick.
Sorry.
Microphone-- thank you.
AUDIENCE: Sorry if I
missed this because I
was late, but in
deconstructing things,
is there ever a
danger of bringing up
negative emotions that you might
not have the capacity to deal
with at any certain time?
Do you have to be careful
about when you go and approach
those things?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Good question.
To do this work,
you have to have
a tremendous amount of patience
and compassion with yourself.
We have this idea that
we need to be perfect.
And we're not.
And we beat ourselves up a
lot around that, most people.
Life is a process.
Meditation is a process.
Mindfulness is a process.
You will find, when you
start paying attention
to these different
trends and patterns--
there are some that I want to
talk about in a minute that
are kind of general.
But what you'll find is
some of the bigger things
do start to come up.
Sometimes, they're hidden.
You didn't just pay attention
to them for a long time.
Or you kind of
know they're there,
but you don't want
to look at it.
There comes a time,
when you start
deconstructing these, where
you can no longer ignore it.
It gets too loud.
So for me, my big thing--
and I had a very big issue.
I had a tremendous amount
of anger in my consciousness
all the time.
And it took me a while to be
able to see it, to accept it,
to start to deal with it.
These smaller things that I
want to talk about in a moment--
some of these initial things
you can do-- are pretty easy,
and they're kind of fun, in
a weird way, to deconstruct.
But when it gets to
the bigger things,
yeah, that can take a while.
And there were times that
I was ready to walk away.
I couldn't handle it.
What I learned to do was, from
a very scientific-- all of you
guys are smart, analytical.
You wouldn't be here
if you weren't I
started to turn it into a game.
Let me figure out
what's going on here.
So with the anger,
when would it come up?
What were the different flavors?
What were the triggers?
In what circumstances?
Was it more jealousy focused?
Was it more control focused?
Was it a fear thing?
What was going on there?
And some of these things,
what I started to recognize
was I could deconstruct those
pretty fast, some of them.
I could spot what it was--
and, OK, let's not do that.
Let's break that habit.
You have to go down to
a level of something
to understand why
you're doing it.
And it's usually never
as bad as we think it is.
But understand why it's there.
Once you are really able to
face it, it loses it's power.
You don't have to
indulge in it anymore.
But there was a time, yeah, I
didn't know which way to go.
I had this whole world
of anger in my head.
And it was never outward.
It was always inward-- angry at
myself and angry at the world.
It really pissed me off,
having all that anger.
[LAUGHTER]
It shouldn't be this hard.
And this is why I'm
such an advocate for it.
It changed my life tremendously.
There were many-- I don't
want to say dark days.
There were dark years.
It was difficult.
I did go to a
counselor for a while.
I found a therapist,
because none of my friends
are going to tel me the truth.
My family's not going
to tell me the truth.
And I wouldn't want to put
them through that, either.
I care for them too much.
It would get personal.
So I found a therapist.
The guy was great.
He had a mohawk.
And I'm like, oh, I
can deal with you.
You're great.
You would be a great therapist.
I saw him for a
while, and he was
willing to point out
those things to me.
Just in conversation, he was
able to-- why do you do this?
Why do you do that?
Where's this?
Where's that?
And it totally opened my
eyes up to certain things.
I became very
strategic about it.
I hiked every weekend.
Nature is amazing to help clear
you out and calm you down.
I was out in nature every
weekend, just religiously.
But there comes a
point where you're just
willing to look at it.
To me, I had no alternative.
I knew too much, if you would.
There was only getting through
it that would take care of it,
being willing to look at it.
So yeah, it can be difficult.
You're going to
have stuff come up.
And I know people have different
difficult childhoods-- abusive,
all kinds of stuff, issues,
and things of that nature.
If it gets to be too much,
then I would say seek out help.
Find someone-- a
therapist, a counselor--
someone that you can work
with or talk to about it.
But the beautiful
thing-- and while I
was going through this,
while it was so difficult,
at least I knew I
was working on it.
At least I was trying.
And there would be gaps in
time where I'd walk away.
I just couldn't deal
with it anymore.
I would try and keep
myself distracted.
But it was always at the
back of my attention there.
But because I was able to A,
get quiet through meditation,
and B, take care of some
of these smaller things
that I'll talk about in a
moment, I knew it was possible.
I knew I could do it.
And it was hard to
deny that truth.
But everyone's different.
For me, I knew I
needed to do it,
because I knew it
could get better.
And I was just willing
to do what it took.
But it wasn't pretty.
But that's my thing.
And that also taught me, though,
everyone's got their thing.
Everyone's got their thing.
And it teaches you a
tremendous amount of compassion
for people in the world.
Everyone's got their thing
that they're trying to work on.
And everyone's trying
to do the best they can
with what they
have, in my opinion.
So how can I even
judge another person?
I don't live in that world.
If I can help in some
way, that's great.
But good question.
Any other questions?
OK.
So some of these
things that I initially
saw when I was paying attention,
monitoring my thoughts-- there
are certain patterns that
pretty much everyone indulges
in-- judgments, expectations,
focusing on the future
and on the past.
That's typical with mindfulness.
But judgments were
really interesting.
When I started to
notice judgments,
just being aware
of what judgments
I was making, when
I was making them,
how often they would come up,
it was freaking incessant.
They were happening all
the time-- good, bad, ugly.
What's interesting
that you'll notice
when you engage in a judgment
against something in the world,
it either kind of boosts
your ego up a little bit
or it pushes you
down a little bit.
So if I'm trying to keep a
constant of just peace-- again,
I don't like to say "happy"--
just kind of peace and content
all day long, each time I would
engage in these judgments would
cause a ripple in that.
And a lot of times, they
would feed on each other.
So if I noticed with a
judgment against something,
I started to see that this
was a bit of an equation.
And a lot of these things are
these interesting paradigms.
If I make a judgment
against something
in the world-- a person--
it's basically boosting my ego
up a little bit.
I'm better than that.
I have the right to judge that.
It's good or it's bad.
My attitude, my ego
is superior enough
to be able to judge
something else
as a good thing or a bad thing.
And I'm not talking about
ethics or morals here.
This is just ugly, not
ugly, lazy, whatever.
And it boosted my
ego up a little bit--
that I am entitled be
able to judge that person.
Conversely, if I had a
judgment against me--
I'm not worthy enough of that or
I'm a bad person-- it pushed me
down.
So when it pushed my ego up,
it gave me a very false sense
of security and control.
We don't have any control.
We have a nice
illusion of control,
but we have no control, really.
We can control our states
of mind and our actions,
and that's about it.
So it boost my ego up
and make my perception
of the world a
little bit stronger,
made me a little
bit more combative.
I know better.
I have the right to judge
that thing, that person, that
experience.
It is what it is.
It doesn't need my judgment.
It exists as it is.
And it's perfect as it is.
I don't need to indulge in that.
So that was one
small thing that I
did that I was able to
just drop from doing.
And when you start seeing
how many judgments you make
in a day, it's fascinating.
They're happening all the time.
And if you can let go of
that, it frees up that space.
You don't have to
indulge in that.
Or you don't have to
push yourself down.
You don't have to compare
yourself to anyone else
or to the world.
So that's just
one example of how
you would indulge in
thoughts that drive you
off course, if you will.
Any questions?
Yeah.
Let me-- oh.
AUDIENCE: Why does the mind
beat me up about mistakes?
It's like there's probably a
mistake I made some time ago,
and there are things I've
done to fix it and all that.
But it's like I keep
going back and revisiting.
Is it trying to
teach me a lesson?
Why does it make me go
back and relive the moment?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Is
it a specific mistake
that you're going back to?
Or is it a recurring one?
AUDIENCE: No, like
three or four.
It doesn't matter.
I feel like I'm always
drawn to previous events.
And maybe I'm trying to
learn from them so that I
don't make the mistake again.
But it's always pulling me back.
And these thoughts come up at
random times, and I don't why.
MICHAEL BROOKS: Well, OK.
So pay attention
when it does come up.
Pardon me.
What you may find are there
are certain triggers that
cause those things to happen.
It could be the environment.
It could be people
who you're around.
you're talking to.
You just want to start to
understand the landscape.
When these things come up,
what's going on in my life?
And am I under a
lot of pressure?
Do I have a fear
of failure, which
is what this maybe sounds like.
What's the fear of failure?
Why are you afraid?
And who's going to
judge that failure?
What are you comparing
yourself against
to think that it's a failure?
Now, with mistakes and
looking back in the past,
there's nothing we
can do about that.
However, what you can do is
make peace with what you did.
At that point in time, in the
past, you made a judgment.
You did something.
And at that point
in time, you thought
it was the right thing to do.
So how can you blame yourself?
It turned out not to
be the right thing,
but you learned from it.
So you can forgive yourself
and say, at that point in time
in the past, I thought I
was doing the right thing.
It turned out not to be,
but I learned a lesson
and I'm not going
to do that again.
So there's a point where you can
just forgive yourself for it,
if you're willing to do it.
I'm not going to make
that mistake again.
I'm sad that it happened,
but at that point in time,
I thought I was doing
the right thing.
I learned from it.
So just a letting go--
again, it comes back
to this compassion
and this patience.
Now, looking back at some of
these things can be hard to do,
sometimes.
But if you start
to see that there's
a connection between these
different mistakes-- they have
a similar flavor to them--
you can start to examine,
is it really a fear of failure?
Is it a fear of
letting somebody down?
And why is that?
Who are you letting down?
What are you afraid of?
And that's where
you have to just dig
in and start looking at it.
You'll feel it emotionally.
But again, I can't
stress this enough.
You have to be very
compassionate when you do it.
You're trying to let
got of that, in a way.
So take the time to realize
when is it coming up?
Try and understand
what the pattern is.
When do these thoughts come up?
What specific situation?
And so more than likely, it's
tied to some kind of situation
in your life.
At the time it's coming
up, it's probably
tied to something that's
going on that same time.
And there may just
be a carryover fear
of making a mistake
for this mistake.
But I would just say understand
that when you did what you did,
you thought you were
doing the right thing,
and you learned from it?
So what else can you do?
It's where you keep making the
same mistake over and over,
daily, then that's
something you want
to really spend some time with.
But if it's just
something in the past--
I understand regrets,
but there comes
a time where you just
have to make amends
with it, with yourself.
And that's really
all that matters.
You just have to
forgive yourself,
if that's the right word to use.
Does that help?
All right.
Good question, though.
Any other questions
along this line?
OK.
So another thing that
I found fascinating
when I was starting to pay
attention to the chatter that
was going on was expectations.
This one was hysterical
to me, because I daydream.
I come up all kinds of
stuff, or I used to.
Expectations-- similar
kind of paradigm.
In this moment
right now, I'm going
to project into the future--
over which I have control,
but I like to think I do--
some future situation that's
going to happen, a date,
maybe Friday night.
It's going to go great.
It's going to be really good.
And in my mind, I'm
going to play out
that entire date in my head.
And I'm going to experience
all the wonderful emotions that
are going to go on at
that time in the future.
And it's not just
a one time thing.
Between now and Friday,
which is only a day,
I'm going to start coming
up with other scenarios
over and over again.
It's going to take up
a lot of my attention.
I'm going to come up with all
these different avenues, how
everything's going to go,
what they're going to say,
what I'm going to respond to.
Ill be so witty and charming.
They'll look this way.
I'll look that way.
Of course, it's
going to be great.
How often does that work out?
So that moment
arrives in the future.
How often does it play out to
one of those scripts exactly?
Ever?
Anyone?
And what's funny is that at
that time in the future, when
you were planning all this
stuff out in the future,
you weren't thinking
at that time
that as that was going
on that you would
be going through head, trying
to figure out all these scripts
and trying to match and figure
out what the next thing to do
is.
You were just having a great
time in the future there.
So it doesn't even match up
to what you were planning.
So expectations can be
really interesting as well.
How often do you do
this as opposed to just
letting an experience
happen organically?
Now, you can prepare for it.
Great.
Get dressed, look nice.
Yeah.
But just let it play out.
Organic experiences are
so much more interesting
than trying to force something
to happen over which you really
have no control.
So it can become a bit of
a game when that happens.
So I did this all the time.
And it took up a
tremendous amount
of time and my consciousness.
And it would go down all
these different routes
whenever I would plan
one of these things out.
It would go great.
It would go down.
But I would experience all
these emotions in this moment.
But that date's not
happening in this moment.
This is what's
happening, only this,
hence the title of my book.
There's only ever this moment.
So there was a willingness
to let go of that.
To see the results of doing
that over and over again just
didn't help.
So I let go of it.
And now, I catch myself.
I was about to
engage in it again.
Just don't do it.
It's a habit.
Just refrain from doing it.
And see what it's like.
So when I was able to let
go of these smaller things,
the world got a lot more easier.
My mind was pretty much
calm most of the day.
But going back to your point,
when I started taking apart
these smaller things,
little habits,
the bigger things
started to show up.
And I recommend just
slowly, gradually
starting to look at those.
They take however long they
need to take to unravel.
Yeah?
You wanna get to--
AUDIENCE: I'm curious, and if
you are comfortable sharing--
if not, fine.
But when you're
talking about that kind
of global reservoir of anger,
did you find a source for it?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah.
There were a number
of sources for it.
Mainly, it had to do with
fear and control and issues
around that.
There were different
flavors in there.
But when I would take
everything down to the core,
I could see there was
just a fear of something.
And I would use anger as
a way to compensate for it
or to feel like I had control.
The anger gave me control
over the situation.
If I could be pissed off
at it, then it was OK.
I didn't have to
be afraid of it.
But then I had to
look at the fear.
What does this fear
have to do with?
And that got to be very subtle
in different situations.
Why did I care?
What was I afraid of?
We push away fear so much.
And you have to take
it at your own time
to be able to look
at these things.
But that was the
core of really what
was going on with mine--
different variations
[INAUDIBLE] of fear, different
manifestations of it.
But it was fascinating
when I would see it.
And it had different
flavors to it,
but I was able to figure
out what the triggers were.
Sometimes, it would
last for weeks on end,
because I was just
holding onto it.
I couldn't let go of it.
And part of it' like
the electric fence.
You hold on and
you can't let go.
So I had to ride it out.
But it was very
difficult at first
trying to understand
it or figure it out,
but I kept continuing to
look, kept continuing to look.
There are things that
you'll learn how to do.
When you're in a
certain state of mind,
we often think that we're
stuck in that state of mind.
So when I was stuck
in anger, I thought
there was no way out of it.
But there were tips and
tricks that I learned
to help break me out of anger.
For me, movies are therapy.
I go to a movie, and I go away.
I get so involved in the movie
that I forget about my life.
And you can try this.
Everyone's got their thing.
But before I went
into a movie, I'd
be in a certain state of mind,
certain state of attention.
Usually, when I came out, I
was in a much better state
of attention, because I was
able to let go for a while.
There was a week straight
I want to move every night.
It was just so bad.
What time does the
next movie start?
And coming out of it,
I would be so clear.
And I'd be like,
OK, now, I'm clear.
Let me try and figure it out
one why I'm in a clear state.
But then the next day, I
would indulge in it again
and bring it all back up.
So yeah.
You figure out what
the triggers are,
what are the things that
help pull you out of it.
I became very
strategic around it.
Like I said, I went
hiking every weekend.
That always cleared me out.
That was always beautiful.
And my god, here, please,
if you're not getting out
every weekend to this
beautiful area that we live in,
please take time
to go into nature.
It clears you out
so beautifully.
So you'll figure out your
things, your triggers, and then
what helps pull you out.
It's fascinating, because
you'll feel the triggers start
to get pulled again, and once
you've kind of figured it out,
you don't have to pull it.
But there's this
habit of just, oh, OK.
Same thing happens
in meditation.
And again, meditation
is a practice.
I've been doing it 20 years.
I'm no master by any means.
But I'm light years
from where I started.
You can get to a
point in meditation
where you're actually
able to get quiet.
Again, you want a focal
point try and keep
your mind focused so it's not
indulging in all this chatter.
And you can get to a point
where you're just still.
And again, it kind of goes back
to that everything's OK in that
moment.
And you'll feel the urge to
start thinking about something,
and you just don't do it.
You say, I don't have to do it.
And you're able to just
stay there and hold onto it.
And that's the most
beautiful feeling.
So thank you.
Good question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So what's the difference
between clearing out,
like a hike or a movie,
versus distracting yourself
from actually acknowledging
what's going on in your head
and trying to pick it apart?
So instead of watching
TV on end and I
don't want to deal with
the right now versus,
OK, I just need
some time to relax
and then I go back to
not being a distraction?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah.
We go through many
states of mind in a day.
But sometimes, when we're
going through something,
there's just this
thread that stays there.
So with me, that thread
of anger was always there.
Yes, you need to take breaks.
But even when I take a break,
that thread was still there.
I could still feel
it panging at me.
When I would go
to a movie, I was
able to stop it because
I was distracted.
The movie distracted me.
And I could just give my
attention to that fully,
be fully present, fully focus
on that, and I forgot about it.
The thread went away.
And so when I came
out, I'm like, oh,
the thread's not there.
I'm clear.
I'm in a clearer state
of attention right now.
Let's maybe spend
some time and maybe
examine it without
getting pulled back
into it, which got to be
tricky, because once I started
to examine it, it would
come up-- process.
So to me, taking a
break and clearing out
is to break that thread for
a little period of time.
But yes, of course, take
care of yourself as well.
It goes back to what
I mentioned earlier.
You've got to have
the compassionate
with yourself and the
patience to just ride it out.
But if you can figure out the
triggers that help pull you out
of a state of mind-- and I
had a whole arsenal of things
after a while-- you
start to figure out
when you can use them and
when it's OK to kind of let
that thread be there.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICHAEL BROOKS: Would
you mind passing it back?
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So when
you're thinking
about all these judgments and
expectations and things like
that, your mind's just
going kind of crazy,
what do you give
it to do instead?
Because it's so used
to doing something,
you can say stop doing that,
but then it sits there,
and a second later, it comes up.
And in meditation,
I know there's
so many things, but in
real life, what do you do?
You're in the shower, you know?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah.
Your mind has a mind
of its own, right?
God bless it.
Again, just to
clarify, this awareness
of what the chatter is-- again,
as I said, some of this stuff
is esoteric-- there's a
part of you that's just
aware of what the thoughts are.
You can think of it like just
clouds passing over the sky.
You're just watching it.
Try not to evaluate
what you're thinking,
which is tricky to do.
But you just want to
be aware of what's
going on so you can figure
out the trends and patterns.
So going back to
what you are, what's
going on when this
worry comes up?
Am I around certain people?
Am I indulged in a
certain activity?
What's happening?
So that's part of it.
The other part is
just trying to see,
wow, I'm making a
lot of judgments,
or I'm doing a lot of
things with my mind.
Some of the tips
that you can do,
some of the classical
mindfulness tricks
that you can use--
chanting is wonderful.
And it doesn't need to be
some kind of spiritual chant.
This was something else
that helped me when
I was in really dark states.
I would just chant over and
over, I'm at peace I'm in love,
I'm at peace, I'm in love,
I'm at peace, I'm in love.
I would do this for
like an hour and half.
And I would try and put all
of my focus on chanting that.
And the miraculous thing
was about an hour and a half
later, I felt such peace
and I felt such love.
And I was able to
pop out of the anger.
So that was one
thing that helped me.
In the shower, you want
to-- classical mindfulness--
bring your awareness
to what you're doing.
Feel the water
hitting your body.
Try and take your attention,
what you're focusing on,
off of all the
chatter, if you can,
and focus on the water
hitting your body, your feet
on the cold tile, the color
of the tiles in the shower,
the speed of the water coming
out, the temperature of it.
Trying to put your focus on
the external really helps.
When you're trying to
be mindful all day,
you're not a zombie
in any way or state.
Someone asked me at one
class, well, what did you did,
just stand there all day?
I'm like, that would be great.
Yeah, I love that.
I've got a busy life.
I can't do that.
You're focused on
what you're doing
to the exclusion
of everything else.
So if I'm writing an email, let
me focus on writing an email.
Typically, when we sit
down to write an email
and we're just going to check
a web page three hours later
and 200 websites
later, you're like,
oh, I was just going
to write an email.
Crap.
So it's this kind of discipline.
Sit down and do
what I need to do.
Focus on doing this one thing
to the exclusion of everything
else.
It's trying to train
yourself away from scattered
and going all over the
place to just focus
on what you're doing.
It's focus and concentration
not taught the world today, not
fostered in the world today.
We're distracted a
bazillion times a day
with our cellphones.
I think they're
saying now, studies
are saying 50 to 100 times we
check our cellphones a day,
if not more.
So we're distracted, right?
That's this world
that we live in.
So to focus and
concentrate on something
can just be a little
weird sometimes.
So it's just building
up the discipline
to stay focused on
what you're doing.
Now, this was a
number of years ago
that I was at a medical
device company down the road,
working with them.
And I was doing that same thing.
It was just loud.
It was a loud day.
And I'm like, OK,
chanting is not
working, because after a while,
you chant the same thing over
and over, it kind
of loses its power
and you think you're chanting
but you're actually thinking
and it becomes this whole mess.
So I'm like, OK, I need
to figure out something
else just to keep me
focused, to keep me
in this present awareness.
So I don't know why
this came to me,
but I was walking
down this ugly hall
and I just started chanting,
I'm walking down an ugly hall.
I am walking down an ugly hall.
That's all I'm doing.
Honestly, in that moment, I'm
just walking down an ugly hall.
So chanting that made me
be present in that moment.
I am just walking
down an ugly hall.
That's all I'm doing.
And chanting that just
drove me into that moment.
I'm looking at an ugly plant.
I don't need to judge, even
though I'm calling it ugly.
It was a pretty ugly plant.
[LAUGHTER]
I was like, this
is what I'm doing.
I'm just doing this.
And that shifted
me in such a way.
I couldn't deny it.
And it really showed
me, wow, your mind
is really all over the place.
Just do this.
Just chant this,
what you're doing.
I'm walking down the street.
I'm washing the dishes.
Washing the dishes, I think, is
classical mindfulness exercise.
But here, this is one of those
things where you're really
focused on the senses.
You put away all the
judgments about washing dishes
and how much you'd rather just
put them in the dishwasher.
But you put the dishes up.
And you look at
the pretty patterns
that the plates make with
all the food on them.
And then you just focus.
You bring your focus
into this moment.
All I'm going to do
is wash the dishes.
And you focus on what you feel.
You reach out.
You feel the knob
on the sink faucet.
You turn it.
You feel the pressure.
You feel the muscles that
have to engage to do that.
You watch the water come out.
You feel the water get warmer.
You put the soap in.
You watch the bubbles come up.
You smell the soap.
You pick up the dishes.
You put them in.
You feel the suction as
they go under the water,
the movement of them, right?
You're forcing yourself
into that moment.
And you can actually
say all this to yourself
while you're doing
it, because it just
helps you get right there.
And if you try this
exercise-- I don't
know if you guys have
ever tried this--
but it's very entertaining.
It turns dish washing into a
totally different experience.
But that's always going on.
Amazing experiences are
going on in every moment.
We're just so caught up
in our head all the time,
we miss them.
It's just the smallest things.
I remember walking out
after a rough day at work.
And I would stop sometimes,
because the sunset
in front of me and the
trees, with the wind blowing
through it and the
birds flying by
would just stop me in my tracks,
the most beautiful thing.
And I'm like, I
see this every day,
but oh my god,
this is beautiful.
And so just giving
myself permission
to acknowledge that and
see that-- so it's a shift.
And it takes time.
So you can come up
with different games.
I have a number of things
in the book that help.
But that was just
one of them, and one
that was really
effective, which is
say what you're
doing to yourself.
And you can't deny it
as you're chanting it.
And it makes it OK, in a way.
I don't need to be thinking
about these others things,
because really, I'm
giving my attention
to what I'm doing right now.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
MICHAEL BROOKS:
Yeah, you're welcome.
OK.
Any other questions?
Oh, good.
AUDIENCE: So tax
season's coming up.
So April 15th comes by.
If I wasn't thinking about
the future to a certain extent
leading up to then, I'm going
to have kind of a difficult day.
So do you have any advice for
arriving at a day like that
and having everything done while
staying present the whole time,
while planning for the future?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Sure.
Yeah.
We've got to live our lives.
There are things
that need to be done.
The car needs to be gassed up.
We need to go travel
to visit family.
We need to do these things.
So again, it's not that you're
a zombie in any way, shape,
or form.
On the weekend, I
sit down, and I've
got my desk full
of stuff that needs
to be done that I had put off.
I said, OK, I'll focus
on it this weekend.
Or I know, yeah, I'm starting
to get the W-2s in the mail,
so I need to start
looking at the tax
stuff, that time of year.
So it's an awareness,
like a deadline.
Of course, at work,
I've got this deadline.
So at this moment, let me plan
out when I'm going to do that.
So planning is part
of being present,
to say, OK, I need to plan out--
I've got a deliverable here
and a deliverable there.
Then I've got to rebuild it over
here or whatever. [INAUDIBLE]
tax season, or taxes
are due this day.
When would be the just
right time to do that?
Let me schedule that
into my calendar.
And then when that time
comes, OK, now, it's
time to work on the tax stuff.
And it may get trumped.
Project management--
things change every day.
I have to reschedule,
gotta replan.
OK.
Let me replan.
I'll do it at another time.
So yeah, you've got to take time
to live your life and structure
things out, for sure.
Again, you're not a zombie.
There are things that you
have to get done in the world
and being and living in the
world to take care of them.
So it's just planning how you
need to take care of things
in your life, really.
Did that help?
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you
help other people?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Oh, in general?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
When you think about, I want
to be helpful to someone else,
how do you think about that?
MICHAEL BROOKS: It's tricky.
Sometimes what we think is
helpful may not be helpful.
You'll learn, especially
with mindfulness,
a tremendous amount of
gratitude and humility
towards other people.
You understand everyone's
fighting their own battle.
You can think
about what can I do
that might help them, in a way?
And who am I to say that
I can help somebody?
Maybe I can, maybe I can't.
Maybe I'll say something
that helps them in a way.
I think it's compassionate to be
there for them if they want you
to-- if they don't want you
to, being compassionate enough
to walk away from it.
But I think honoring
people is the biggest
thing you can do
for other people,
and understand that they're
fighting their own battle,
and if they want
help, helping them.
It's nice to show gratitude
always for everything,
whenever you can.
And gratitude is one of the
best tools that we have.
You can be helping somebody
just by thanking them
for doing something for you
or going out of your way
to do something for them because
they did something for you,
or just going out of your way.
You can help the guy at
the grocery checkout.
He's standing there
for eight hours a day.
I would not want that job.
So I can maybe help him
in a way by just cracking
a joke when I'm
with him or making
him smile for a moment
of that eight hours.
But not doing it for me-- maybe
I can do something for them.
And that's part of what
you have to look at, too,
part of this examination.
Is the motive to make me
feel better for myself
by helping them?
Or am I truly being
of service to them?
So there's the
egotistical I'm helping
or there's just the being
of service to somebody
without expecting
anything in return.
So again, how do we
really help anyone?
I think just being compassionate
as best we can is important.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I would just add
one comment to that.
I try to do that kind
of thing every day
here at Google, with all of
the people who serve us and do
all the dirty work that makes
our life a lot easier day
to day at Google-- driving
the bus, serving the food--
all these roles that
you see around campus.
Just saying a simple thank you,
or the meal was really tasty
or whatever-- it does make a
difference in those people's
day.
You can tell that
it matters to them.
I find personal satisfaction
in helping them.
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah, no.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] it makes
me feel better about myself.
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
somewhat self-serving.
But I know that it's
helping them too.
MICHAEL BROOKS: No,
there's definitely
a symbiosis that happens
there when you're doing.
It's selfless
giving, if you will.
But being helping others,
just by saying that,
helps them and helps you.
It lightens you up, in a way.
So yeah, no.
Good point.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I actually don't
have a question for you.
But I just wanted-- I'm the
gPause program manager here
at Google.
It's our program for
building communities
of mindfulness practices here.
Is there anyone here who doesn't
know about the gPause program?
OK, well then-- oh.
Well, since you're
the only one, you
could just talk to me later.
But I just wanted to
say, in the vein of your
being mindful
throughout the day,
we had a mindfulness
week last month.
And we were giving out these
bands, which you can wear.
They're Google-y color
bands that say gPause on it.
If anyone would like one that
wasn't part of that week,
just see me afterwards.
But that's something you
can use to remind yourself
throughout the day to do
things you were talking about.
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah,
those reminders are great.
Yeah, and I don't know
if you caught at first.
I really am amazed at what
this organization does
in terms of mindfulness and
meditation for the staff.
It's fantastic.
AUDIENCE: We have
three meditation rooms
at the back of this
building, by the way.
And there's a guided, there's
a led sit at 11:30 every day
[INAUDIBLE], just
in this building,
but also all across campus.
MICHAEL BROOKS: Yeah.
And I hope that catches
on at more organizations.
I hope to see more
of it in the world.
AUDIENCE: Just a
quick question--
I'm sure you have lots of
tricks and tips in your books.
But I think one of the
questions or one of the things
which is bugging me is
if you have this churn
and you are thinking, you have
easy things you can probably
pull yourself out.
But what happens when you
are in a spur of the moment--
your experience, you get angry
easily, so when you get angry,
you get angry.
So do you have any
tip for that, things
which happen in
spur of the moment,
where you really don't have
time to do this observation
or pull yourself out?
MICHAEL BROOKS: Too busy
being angry to do anything
about my angry-- I don't know
if there's anything specifically
that you can do.
You can recognize
what's happening.
That's important.
Most of the time, I didn't
realize what was going on.
It was, again, back of my mind.
The recognition that
it's happening--
and if there's something you
can do to try and calm yourself
down, or if there are any other
tips that you come up to help
temper it, or get out
of that situation.
If it's getting to
a detrimental point,
exit the situation as best you
can, and as cleanly as you can.
If you can see-- and I would
see this with the anger--
that it would go
down a certain road.
Once you notice that
there's a pattern,
it's going to go down this road.
OK, let's change the course.
Let's just not do it.
So if it's an encounter
or maybe a relationship
with a certain person that
always gets very tense,
then just try not to
get into that situation.
A, avoid the situation until
you get a better handle over it
and what's going on.
But two, if you see that it's
kind of going down that path
and you have an exit,
then try and exit,
get away from it, until
you're able to look at more
and maybe defuse it somewhat.
But it's also good to see,
once you've recognize a habit
and you're trying things, to
go into that situation and see,
is working or not?
OK, that didn't help.
I went down the path again.
Let's come back and try again.
Let's figure out something else.
I think it is really trial
and error for whatever
your unique circumstance is.
But awareness is
the biggest key.
The fact that you're aware of
what's going on-- same thing
with meditation.
You've got to be aware.
Most of the time, we're unaware.
We're on auto pilot.
It's just going its
own course But the fact
that you're aware of it is
a tremendously wonderful
good first step.
At least you're aware.
And that awareness
will deepen over time.
You'll become more and
more aware over time.
So thank you.
AUDIENCE: So for someone who
wants to get into meditation,
what do you think about
camps like the vipassana camp
or something, where you go
away for a week or 10 days
and you just focus on
that versus just getting
into it slowly and slowly?
MICHAEL BROOKS: I haven't
tried one of those.
If it resonates with
you, give it a shot.
I know there are people that
go away on trips to India
or something for meditation,
and it really helps them.
And I hear it's also very
painful to go through it.
Sometimes, for me, silent
meditation technique
is the most difficult
one out there.
I don't recommend
it to start with.
But only you know your own pace
and what you're willing to do.
If you're OK being
somewhere for a week
and really just gutting
through it, that's great.
But if you have a pattern of
trying to gut through things
and giving up and
walking away, then I
don't recommend doing it.
Again, understand what
your patterns are.
I think it's good, first,
before just jumping
in somewhere for a week, go to
a couple of meditation classes.
In fact, try a couple out.
Try a couple of
techniques out, a couple
of locations, because
you want to find
one that resonates with you.
If you're stuck
somewhere for a week
and it doesn't
resonate with you,
that's just going to be torture.
But if you can find
vipassana or something
along those lines where it's
kind of speaking to you, like,
OK, this is working for me,
try that a number of times.
And then maybe go for a week.
But a full immersion
for week somewhere
where you don't know-- that
could be really tricky.
Any other questions?
OK.
So the one thing that I
say take away from this
is as I was just saying,
just start becoming
aware of what you're thinking.
Just start paying attention
to what's going on.
And have the belief that you
can get to more quiet, more
peaceful states of mind.
But it is a process.
You don't need to be
perfect now or tomorrow.
What is perfect?
It's a journey
with no end to it.
But there's a deepening
with all of it
as well, a beauty in that.
So moments of quiet
and meditation,
they just deepen over
time-- the beauty and peace
that you can experience in
meditation and in mindfulness.
In the most weird situation,
walking in the mall,
you can be like, wow,
this is beautiful.
This mall is amazing.
The colors, the lights, the
sounds, the people, big circus,
but-- the world can become
very magical for you.
But just start paying
attention to what's going on.
And then start to navigate that.
And slowly start
to deconstruct it.
The book that I wrote,
it is available.
Allen's got some at
the back if you're
interested in buying one.
But they're on Amazon.
It's on Kindle, all of
the electronic versions.
I do have a website,
thisonlythis.com.
I do post memes and
sections from the book.
I've done a couple of radio
interviews, podcast interviews.
So those are all
up on the website
if you want more information.
And you can also email
me through that, as well,
if you have interest.
So thank you for your time.
I greatly appreciate
it, you coming out here
and spending your
time with me, not
really knowing what I was
going to talk about except
for mindfulness.
So I appreciate that time, and
the questions very much so.
And if you have
additional questions,
feel free to stay after.
I'd love to talk to you more.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]